I want you to think about the most
embarrassing moment you've ever had in
business as an entrepreneur then I want
you to hear my 10 and see if you've
beaten any one of these 10 okay so
before I embarrass myself and share
these 10 embarrassing stories of mine as
an entrepreneur I want to remind
everybody if you look at the number of
subscribers I think will run seven
hundred fifty thousand subs which means
we're only 250 thousand subs away from
crossing a million and when we do we're
doing our first live value teaming
conference I know many of you around the
world have sent me messages saying what
are we doing this we are this close it
can happen anytime I've told you 90 days
after we cross a million subs we'll do
our first live value timing conference
for two and a half days to talk about
business cannot wait for that day and
having said that let me get into the
first most embarrassing story of me as
an entrepreneur here we go number one so
one day I'm giving this speech in my
office back in 2006 and I'm trying to
sell everybody on what we're doing and
it's very important for me to get
everyone's attention everyone stay
focused and as I'm going through it one
person walks out right after this person
walks that I have to set the tone I said
listen I kind of need all your attention
I'm not gonna walk out but I need 45
minutes of undivided attention if you do
need to use a restroom and you're
pregnant that's totally okay but if
you're not pregnant please stay here
with me so I went through it 20 minutes
later this lady gets up and she starts
walking on so she walks that I'm like Oh
totally fine she's walking out she had a
pouch and I said you know it's no
problem I said she's okay to walk out
because she's pregnant ma'am if you go
out the bathrooms to your left and she
looks at me with the biggest look of
frustration and disappointment and anger
she says how dare you I'm not pregnant
and she walks out the look on my face I
wanted to find the smallest hole in the
room to just hide him and I couldn't
find it
I was so embarrassing somehow someway I
regained the group and everybody kind of
started feeling bad for me and berries
for me but we kept going on
very embarrassing moment if you haven't
done something like that I don't ever
recommend you using that number two okay
so let me share this one with you I was
in Bermuda just recently and I'm getting
there to celebrate award ceremony Goshen
was going out with a four billion dollar
company but one of the nights I was
walking across the stage and being
recognized for the production that we
had done so we get there on Tuesday my
luggage stays there in Miami it doesn't
arrive till Saturday we're leaving
Sunday so by the time the luggage
arrives we leave the next day award
ceremonies on Wednesday night and I have
nothing to wear I'm thinking it's gonna
show up every day it never shows up and
by the time I want to go get something I
don't have anything so I buy the local
stuff I don't have a time just won a
suit tie I don't have any shoes my size
to buy some warm flip-flops I was the
only guy in the awards ceremony room
walking around with a suit and
flip-flops on walk it across the stage
people are looking at me saying look at
that middle Easterns feet right there
hairy Middle Eastern feet legs on stage
people are taking pictures of it and I
even have proof of it on how this thing
happened this is what I look like that
day I'm trying to make a fashion
statement here since our bags are still
in Miami Wow you like those Ferragamo's
no shoes no socks see what they're gonna
say about it number three most
embarrassing story as an entrepreneur
okay so it's 2010 the Lakers are facing
the Celtics and it's game seven I'm
trying to get tickets to go to it
finally an attorney sells me these nice
tickets for $6,000 and I said I'm gonna
call a friend I call my friend pastor
Dudley brother if I said woody he's a
big diehard Lakers fan he says let me
think about it so he offers to take the
car I said I'll Drive you myself I pull
up I pick him up by my office he gets in
this yellow zo6 that I have and we're
flying on the way there the 210 freeway
which is known for having a worst
reception because of the mountains my
zo6 runs out of gas and by the way if
you don't know I have the reputation for
having ran out of gas in my cars at
least 50 times maybe more
so we're there there's no reception we
keep trying to call this one there is no
reception finally we get a bar we call
the guy shows up from triple-a he knows
me by my first name pastor Dudley
Rutherford's making fun of his saying
how does a triple-a guy know you by your
first name gives me guess he's recording
the entire video we get back in the car
we barely make it
first quarter starts we make it to the
game and obviously the Lakers beat the
Celtics that I think they win their
sixteen or seventeen championship so
it's a great game we come back home I'm
over I thought this is the story right
now I got a reputation on the San
Fernando Valley as a business guys an
entrepreneur I'm kind of shaking it up I
got some enemies I got some competitors
but I'm built on a reputation right it's
been built but it's getting bigger and
bigger so pastor doesn't it cause me
three weeks that he says listen I want
you to come to service because I got a
store I want you to be sitting front row
all the sudden some call no problem you
want me front row I
I bring my dad I bring my wife we're
sitting front no he invited me so I go
sit in the front row and he gets up he
said I want to tell you a story about a
good friend of mine Patrick bud David
can you stand up please I stand up you
know it's kind of like ol hey Lee up
thinking this is like this is this is a
great business guy all this other stuff
and he said Patrick offers to take me to
a Laker game and let me tell you what
happens on the way to a Laker game and
he tells the entire story by the way his
church is 15,000 members he said it at
five different services and it doesn't
stop there let me tell what else happens
he writes a book with a major publisher
in the title the book is God has an app
for that if you buy the book chapter
number one tells you vividly how I ran
out of gas and at the end of the book he
has a link on his website for you to see
how I ran out of gas while he's
recording my yellow zo6
now keep in mind the rest of the time
and valley every time I went to some
other people say aren't you together ran
out of gas you together always runs out
of gas oh my gosh now it was
embarrassing as a businessman but on the
other side it became one the best
conversation starters in San Fernando
Valley so Thank You Dudley Rutherford to
tell the story of me running out of gas
it helped me in business
number four okay so when you're coming
up in business a lot of times you want
to impress the people that have money
for them to think that you are also
serious this is like 2002-2003
let me tell how much money I had in the
bank I probably had five dollars in a
bank if I'm lucky I'm in that forty nine
thousand dollars and everything will my
credit cards I'm hoping there's enough
left so this client if I sell this
client I'm gonna make six thousand
dollars and six thousand dollars at that
time is a lot of money so I go and I
said listen dinners on me tonight of
course I'm gonna take care you guys
don't even worry about I borrow one of
my friends cars and I give the credit
card waiter goes so it's on me he walks
the second time he comes to me and I
said yeah you got her to sign he says no
your card declined so he said it
everybody here I said I'm sorry my car
doesn't the client you need to go run it
again your machine's broken because
sometimes these things happen he goes
back and runs it he comes back but when
he's coming around I spot the look I
said scuse me I got to use the restroom
I walk up I put my handbook behind the
guys back said let's go over here Rokon
need to talk I said listen don't you
ever embarrass me in front of my clients
here says sir your card declined again I
said I know it declined of course they'd
be glad I know it's gonna be Clara was
hoping it wasn't gonna decline finally
we made something work I left I came
back to say listen their machine was
broken it's fixed now I went through
we're good to go can we do business to
get and all that other stuff we
obviously ended up doing business
together but that happened to me
multiple times in my
first you're running a business and if
it happened to you as well it happens to
the best of us
it's okay number five so one time I
recruit this new agent and I'm really
excited about what this guy's gonna do
he's a killer big personality salesman
Elana Kravitz on you know just one of
these guys that I think is gonna do good
and we're driving in my car escalate to
an appointment and we're in Tarzana
California right and we're driving all
of a sudden I see this cop behind me and
he's been following me for like five
minutes like four exits he's following
us and I'm just paying attention and
having a conversation with them and I'm
going 70 miles an hour he pulls me over
and he you know gets out and he's got
his hand I'm like why is he got his hand
on me I know I had one of these
escalates with the black wheels you know
20 inch wheels and you know we would
play some good music so he comes out he
says are you Patrick we're David yes can
you please step out of the car I step
out of the car he says please put your
hands back to put my hands back what's
this guy talk in front of this guy this
guy's thinking I'm a convict I said why
am I doing this sir do you realize your
license has been suspended for eight
months because you have 16 speeding
tickets the entire time this new killer
sales guy that I recruited I'm excited
about is listening to his mentor getting
arrested for having 16 speeding tickets
Wow I have my handcuffs on my arms the
guy says he's getting a report they're
screaming emergency you got to come over
here right now the cop has a bigger
emergency to go to than me and they're
calling on him right he says you know
what I have to go there's nothing I can
do bad about you got to go and get this
thing knocked out of the way he says
just go get your license squirt oh
because your license is suspended he
takes off I get in the car I leave your
and a half later has to go to court in
Palm Springs to fix this thing because
my license was suspended I had a driver
for three months you're gonna get lucky
sometimes like I did when you do take
advantage of it because that was a lucky
day for me number six I had an office in
Woodland Hills California it was a
beautiful office when I take a beautiful
office it was a 1 and a half two million
dollar least eighty six hundred square
feet high-rise just the best place you
walked an elevator entrance beautiful
spot I had so that lease I don't like
being in LA County because you would pay
taxes for being in LA County in
California gave you benefits if you were
in Glendale Burbank County because that
was outside so I said let's move to
Burbank while we're going to Burbank
Glendale I find an office I'm about to
lease so I leased this one out to a guy
that you know did very good for himself
he takes my old office but in between
the office this next one falls through
and the building comes back and says the
number you negotiated someone's willing
to pay 20 cents more than yours were
given to this other guy and I said oh
you gotta be can't be doing this to me
you said we never signed a contract
so because we never signed a contract we
can do that to you last second they give
it to the other guy we don't have an
office let me explain to you for 90 days
we rented a shack well all my employees
are working out of a small Shack on top
of each other
where every day they wanted to kill each
other and every time somebody wanted to
come and deliver business to us we would
tell them where's your office I can we
come and drop off the business no no no
you can't come over here we'd meet him
in the parking line so what's going on
is there like an underground it we just
had a terrible office it was a kitchen
smaller the kitchen we laugh about it
now but for three months our
headquarters was based out of a kitchen
for three months
very embarrassing we're at a big office
now but at one point our office was a
kitchen and number seven this one got to
be one of the most embarrassing ones
this is back in Agoura Hills I was
invited to an office to speak and I was
supposed to give a very intense talk
because that office needed somebody to
challenge him right so I'm gonna come
and give a strong talk so I come up and
I'm speaking room packed 150 people I'm
giving this strong message front row
there's four people sitting here two
girls and they're just like trying to
smile and they're laughing they're like
smiling and going back like what is so
funny and also an iPod so you think this
is funny
are you committed do you really want to
go out there and win and they're like we
do but can I whisper something in your
ear I said yes what do you want to
whisper so I step over here and she
comes and she whispers in my ear she
says Patrick I said yes what your
zippers down I said what your zippers
down let me tell you at this point I'm
like I'm looking on to see who else is
making eye contact down here so I make
my adjustment from here to here my hands
I typically talk like this I never talk
like this this just makes no sense this
is my style of talking I go like this
and hear that magical sound you know
what the magical sound is ready see if
you can hear it one two that sound I did
I make that sound half the room starts
laughing because apparently everybody
knew my zipper was done and I'm trying
to give this intense talk let's just say
this was a difficult one to get
everybody be serious afterwards
everybody said this was when your best
talker was so great because we felt like
we're you're relatable because your
zippers down it was
so awesome I also think I can be like
you one day here's a point here to
realize if you've ever had an
embarrassing moment like this but you
didn't give it a sales pitch or you're
talking to your sales force and your
zippers down in the back your head just
know this Pats also made this mistake
before
number eight okay so one thing about the
insurance industry if you ever turn on
the TV and you're watching a golf
tournament you're gonna see some kind of
a life insurance commercial being done
there which means if you're gonna stay
in the business and you're gonna be very
successful you're going to be invited to
millions of golf tournaments so for me I
avoided it for years until all of a
sudden I couldn't avoid it because I'm
performing with the bigger guys and I
got invited and I got invited to this
one golf tournament they said Pat you've
been selected to golf with these
executives so I said okay I'll go I'm
the athlete right so I'm like oh you
know golf is not gonna be a big that I'm
a big baseball guy you know it was like
a Juan Gonzales guy I know how to hit
the ball I got distance I got strength
I'm gonna kill it it's gonna be great
right before it I gave myself I said one
day I'm gonna go warm up at the bow ball
club it's gonna be good one day's plenty
for me because I'm naturally an athlete
and I go hit the ball I'm like this is
very difficult
how is golf more difficult than baseball
the ball sits there baseball the ball is
moving I can hit the baseball I can't
flip and hit the golf ball so then comes
a tournament so we go to it and I'm tied
with these guys I'm part of this group
and for some all these guys are like the
top guys above everybody and they want
to do because Pat's coming up so we go
listen let me put it to you this way
think about the most embarrassing moment
anybody could have in golf in one day I
don't think anybody's there was more
embarrassing than mine I killed a few
birds I mowed the lawn afterwards the
country club came and said we're hiring
for somebody to mow the lawn if you're
willing to take the job I turned it down
because the pit money wasn't good
everybody's trying to say oh my gosh
you're getting better it's okay hanging
their patient and inside they're going
whispering to each other laughs and
couldn't wait for this 18 hole by the
time nine was and I said listen guys you
go on the next nine I'm taking a break
so in reality sometimes you're gonna get
involved in certain industries that you
have to play certain sports whether you
like it or not if you get into insurance
get ready to golf with somebody someday
number nine so one day I'm sitting in
the sales appointment and this guy walks
and he looks very sharp and I'm looking
at the sky I said man he looks sharper
why does he smell so bad like he smells
terrible did he just go to the bathroom
like man wipe yourself clean yourself
what is wrong with you he smelled
terrible and he's sitting in front of me
and tip
an appointment sales appointment would
take me an hour hour and a half and said
listen I can't sit next to somebody that
smells this bad so I cut this
appointment fast I was very frustrated
said how does somebody have the audacity
to not even take care of themselves when
they come in
I mean his shoes did you step on poop
what is wrong with you so I cut the
appointment very quickly and I said
buddy I got another call I gotta make
we're good to go so he leaves I go I'm
out listen to this guy man I haven't
seen a guy that smelled as bad I've
never done a poem with a guy that smell
this bad so I go to the bathroom and
when I go to the bathroom I look at
myself in the mirror I had my kids
earlier and when I had my kids earlier
on my tie his poop all the way on my tie
okay and the person who smelled like
was this guy here not the guy I'm
selling it to it was embarrassing
because the entire time the man was so
kind so nice to me and you can see the
stains on my tie here he never brought
it up if you're watching this my
apologies to you I promise you moving
forward I will never have poop on my tie
ever again
but if you've ever done a sales
appointment and you're worried about
having one of these things in your teeth
you know how when you look at some of
the identical take that thing out
nothing is gonna be worse than having
poop on your time and last but not least
number 10 okay so me time running the
sales office back in 2005 in Granada
Hills okay and I always came in on
Sundays because Sunday's things were
quiet I could really strategize and
write stuff down to know what I'm gonna
be doing the next week one Sunday I go
in and I'm like wait a minute nobody
parks the car here on Sundays this is
not a place you park the car on Sundays
in Granada Hills right after four or
five freeway two cars are parked outside
so what's going on here so I come
upstairs and by the way there was a way
for you to always sneak into the office
on Sunday because if you had one of
those you know how you put the ID stuff
in the door you know what's wrong I'm
talking on the door open so there was a
way to sneak in but I came in from the
elevator I put my keys in and I'm
hearing stuff what is this is it the
cleaning crew oh god this is not a sound
I recognize for cleaning it shouldn't
sound like this in a moment I opened
door oh it's like you know when it's
like too late when you see something
yeah that was too late already and I saw
it and this couple boyfriend and
girlfriend they're going at it as if
they're shooting a porn movie that day
and I'm watching these guys like the
sound cha-cha loud I'm like and you look
at me like you know the whole look you
mean if you cover you so I'm like guys
I'm uncomfortable what do you guys doing
here it's like it everybody's doing one
of these things right oh my gosh Patrick
we're so sorry I said why here why not
in your apartment
why not in your house but Pat I live
with my parents and he lives with his
parents and our car is too small and it
was a target which is this is the best
place we find I said but could you stand
here on the carpet we train right here
I'm gonna talk right next to this
tomorrow and I said let's um finish off
and just tell me when you guys are done
so I step outside few minutes later they
finish up they come they leave they're
embarrassed the next day is the best day
because x monday morning we have our
monday full-timers meeting we got about
50 people in the office and I get up and
I spot him he's sitting over here she is
sitting over here ok so I get up I said
oh my gosh I got have fun with this I
said listen let me take out something
one of the things that impresses me the
most is when I see people show up on
Sundays to prepare for their week and
let me tell you who showed up this
Sunday to the office of prepare for the
week can we please have such-and-such
stand up and can we have you stand up he
stand up she stands up there sitting I
said listen guys these guys were here on
Sunday strategizing on what they're
going to do to take their business to
the next level I'm so proud of you guys
can we give a round of applause to these
guys their face is so red it's crazy
right
they grab a seat I said I just want you
to I'm very proud of you guys you guys
going places so keep doing what you're
doing right now we can see you at the
top so here's a point by the way this is
one of many many many stories like this
because when you run a sales office
crazy things happen if it's happened to
you before it's happened to many other
sales offices as well it's normal in
sales offices but my recommendation to
you find another place to get it on not
the sales office it throws everybody off
and makes it very awkward so if you're
watching this and it was you we have a
special connection together for the rest
of our lives
listen here's a moral this story I've
had a lot of embarrassing moments and
I'm not really worried about it I'm
probably gonna have many many more
businesses ugly it's not always gonna be
perfect you're gonna have embarrassing
moments scary moments or dumb mistakes
you're gonna make but the key is to keep
going and not let it slow you down I
made two other videos that I think you
ought to watch one of them is scariest
moments of my business
there's 11 scary stories that I tell you
about that I personally experienced that
really shook me you gotta watch this one
the other one is 12 dumbest mistakes I
made as an entrepreneur these two videos
here I suggest you watch both it and
we'll put the link below as well for you
to watch them by the way if you have any
embarrassing moments more than
once I told you about I want to hear
about it tweet me at Patrick big David
with the most embarrassing moments
you've had as an entrepreneur if you
haven't yet subscribe to the channel
click on the sub button right here take
care everybody bye bye
[Music]